hello believe nation welcome to another
edition of the Evan Carmichael show i am
your host Evan Carmichael I believe in
entrepreneurs and this show is all about
helping you turn your business into a
success I'm really excited about today's
show it's the it's the first one of the
new year and I'm talking about social
media success now social media is
something that scares a lot of
entrepreneurs you know you need it you
hear people doing really well with it
you're trying to figure it out you're
not having success that's what this show
is all about today all right let's get
started I love social media you know I
used to hate social media I didn't get
it I didn't understand it I thought you
know what why are people posting
pictures of their cats and what they ate
put it up on Twitter I didn't understand
it you know i'm a busy entrepreneur
you're busy entrepreneur to you got a
million things to do why waste your time
here but I've realized that it could be
a significant growth driver for your
business facebook youtube twitter isn't
just about fun it's about generating new
leads for your company my favorite place
right now is YouTube I'm getting over a
million minutes every no no I'm not
Millie minutes I'm in a million hours I
think every month on on YouTube people
watching the videos people enjoying
people spreading people sharing and it's
it's the feedback in the comments that
everybody shares that keeps me going it
keeps me motivated but also generates
sales generates interest generates a
following and so I'm going to share with
you some of those secrets today on this
show so first I want you to think about
your social media your website does it
look like you did it yourself does it
look at you had a friend help you do it
right it's time to step up your game a
little bit here right for 2015 you got
to step up you gotta rise up you're
gonna you got to make a look like hey
this person knows what they're talking
about and online marketing social media
marketing is one of the best fastest
quickest ways to grow your business if
you look at top ink magazine they do an
annual list every year looking at what
are the most effective ways to grow a
company and
the top is always online marketing so
you got to get in the game it's time to
stand up let's talk about social social
is a it's a long term commitment most
people they approach it from the wrong
way they're on their broadcasts they're
on they're trying to sell constantly you
got to think about it like your
relationship you got to think about it
like like the people who are on your
news ever like the people who you know
might be listening to this radio show I
don't come on this show and say hey you
guys need to go and buy my product you
got to go sign up for all this stuff
that I'm doing because it's amazing
right if this is a sales pitch you would
tune out and that's what you're doing on
social media most people you have to
build a relationship just like you do in
the offline world online is the same as
offline you wouldn't walk up to somebody
on the street and say hey will you marry
me right that's not going to happen how
do you get married you start a
relationship right you get to know the
person you interact you go on some dates
you do the same thing in social you
start by sharing by adding value but
getting to know who's paying attention
to you instead of just going right away
trying to ask for the sale that's a huge
mistake that most people do and you got
to mix up the fun the educational the
promotional stuff you can add daily
quotes from famous entrepreneurs that's
what I do on my channel I have
motivational pictures I have a question
to pull my audience I have contests I
might have a promotion right it's not
all just all fun than inspiration so
there's also calls to action right I
have daily youtube videos that go up
right so you have to have this mix of
blending your personal and your business
to help generate some leads now if
you're afraid you know you might not be
tech-savvy this might be a totally new
thing for you and you think it's
overwhelming I don't know what to do you
have to just start just like anything
else when you first started you're going
to suck your learning it when you're
first learn to ride a bike when you
first learn a new language you sucked at
it that's okay but you can't let that
fear hold you back from getting started
so I want to hop to the calls and enough
i'm going to share some specific tips on
how you can generate some results on
social i have kelly on the line Kelly
where are you from and how can I help oh
hi i am calling from Chicago Illinois
welcome to the program yeah I thank you
thanks for having me on and I have a
question for you can you
in part any advice as to owning and
managing an import retail store I have
an idea a business idea which will
happen and it is selling imports from
Mexico from Mexican artisan with the
percentage going back to the respective
artists kind of like a miniature a very
miniature 10,000 villages however my
shop will also incorporate Mexican
culture with like poetry readings or
like coffees of Mexico or chocolates of
Mexico or recipes or cooking
demonstrations or maybe a travel love so
it's really going to be not just retail
but also a little bit of cultural
exchange for Mexico so I've own two
businesses previously but I've never
been involved in an import in an import
business or in a business of this type
so do you have any advice for me on that
it's exciting it's exciting to launch
this new company I can tell you have
some a personal connection to Mexico two
things I guess one you have to figure
out the logistics and that's the more
boring part right whenever you're
importing something into a country
you've gotta figure out you know what
what are the tax is going to be how is
that going to work out are there any
issues that we have to deal with
although Mexico and the u.s. have easy
relationship than if you're trying to
bring it in from from somewhere else and
the the bigger part is more how do you
then sell it right because you're going
to take a cut of everything that that
comes in so who can you I think about
who can i partner with to sell this
stuff who already has an audience so if
you're looking at who's your target on
so travelers that people who are
interested in Latin American culture
initially it's just going to be a
regular shop or you know your retail
person who wants to pick up that gift or
wants to have you know a piece of
jewelry or your normal regular shopper
but then extending that yeah it would be
somebody who has cultural interest
perhaps in Latin American literature or
in my America
cooking or and it would be specifically
mexicana Stephen Latin America at the
region but yeah we be extended out
toward a more specific audience exactly
and i was thinking in chicago we have in
exchange we have sister cities in Mexico
so I was thinking of working with the
cultural center and so anyway but yeah
you're their different audiences one
will be foot traffic or just your main
your regular shopper and the other one
will be kind of like you're more
cultural oriented person who really
wants to learn as opposed to just spend
money yeah and I would honestly focus
way more on that market then just trying
to target everybody because the people
who really care about learning the
culture and really appreciate the value
of what they're looking at they're going
to spend more with you they're going to
tell more friends about you they're
going to refer more clients who they're
going to they're going to keep coming
back over and over and over again so I'd
be trying to form partnerships so if
it's the sister city thing that's great
I'd be looking at who in Chicago is
talking about Latin culture Mexican
culture who can help be an influencer if
it's a youtuber if it's a blogger if
it's a reporter I try to focus a lot of
these sales online and not just having a
retail location that cost you a ton of
money to open up retail space right
right I would do it as a test honestly
stop like don't go retail yet do it
online build an audience bill traction
poop to yourself that this works before
you dump a whole bunch of money into
into rent and set up because it costs
you so much to have a retail space and
start making partnerships with people
who love the culture who can explain it
who have an audience you know you should
be calling into radio shows that are
promoting Latin culture and tourism and
and you know eco products right if you
had something that would sell to
entrepreneurs you could join my like
this would be a great audience for you
right everybody would be interested in
what your product would be so you want
to attract you know the Me's of the
world but who target your audience and
get them familiar with it so that they
can help push it for you and you're not
doing all the grunt work yourself okay
well that's excellent advice thank you
that's
I've got my work cut out for me don't I
know no problem Kelly do you have a
website no not yet this just happened
this so I mean this idea just happened I
don't have a website up and running its
it is in the process so I've got a
couple partners and one of my partners
is creating the website and we just
decided on a name so and it's very
preliminary but that's why I'm making
the calls now to find out the best way
to proceed so I can work most
efficiently I love it well I as you as
you grow call back in couple a couple
weeks couple months let me know how
you're doing come back with another
question I'd be happy to help out okay
great thank you so much no problem Kelly
thanks for calling in and for everybody
listening if you're getting started
don't go out trying to spend a bunch of
money right don't go out and just open
up a retail shop and hope it's going to
work out start online start small start
making some sales start building some
momentum get your website going get your
social media going prove to yourself
that this will work that you can make
money on it that it's impacting people
that you love doing it before you sink a
bunch of money from a loan or your your
mortgage or your personal savings into
it okay it's really important that you
get that business decision right today
we're talking about how to get results
from your social media campaign so let's
dive into it let's get into the tips my
first tip is you have to listen okay
again I said at first I didn't
understand Twitter people talking with
their cats all these silly things I
thought this isn't there's gonna be a
huge waste of time for me but after a
bit of digging what got me on the
twitter in the first place was somebody
mentioned my website somebody mentioned
my website it was it was good which is
great somebody said hey check out that
mechanical com it's a awesome resource
and I wasn't a part of the conversation
and that made me think well people are
talking about my business I need to at
least be there I need to least be there
to thank them and to be a part of it
even if i'm not posting you know tweets
every day and videos every day if people
are talking about me i want to be a part
of that and that's the same thing for
you right networking
no one is you need to be where your
customers are if your customers are in
this room you want to be in that room
just like Kelly from Chicago who has a
Mexican import business right she wants
to set that up she wants to be in the
room where all the people who are
interested in buying products from
Mexico and Latin America are going to be
so wherever that conversation is
happening that's where Kelly needs to be
so what I want you to do is start
thinking about the main social media
networks you can look at look at the
five look at twitter facebook youtube
linkedin and google okay look at those
five and and do some searching see
people are talking about your products
and services or your industry in general
there if your customers are there then
you want to be a part of that
conversation you want to get engaged
there if they're not then you don't have
to worry about it right then you're
going to be wasting your time all right
nobody on twitter is talking about your
industry your product then you don't
need to be there but do some research to
figure that out number two so that was
that was step number one we're listening
okay step number two is I want you to
create some accounts it's so helpful and
handy to have the account set up even if
you don't use them just to have the
names that nobody can squat on that
company name for you write it costs you
nothing to set up and I want you to go
out in each of those accounts and get
the name it's free and so nobody else
can use their brand in case one day you
want to go and use it you've got it so
step one is listen step two is create
your account okay I want to hit the
calls up again I've got Maria on the
line Maria where are you from and how
can I help hi and thank you for taking
my call and from Long Island New York
and I have a question I wanted to start
a business and I wasn't quite sure do I
start a corporation or do I take it the
other Avenue as LLC I've been advised in
so many directions and I'm a bit
confused sure and it's something that
everybody goes through when the first
starting their company the the biggest
issue is going to be about liability
okay so if something happens with your
business then depending
you set it up you could be sued so you
have to think what's the likelihood of
me being sued right so if you have an
online business and you're selling books
online it's probably a really low
likelihood of you being sued where if
you are teaching people martial arts
right if somebody gets kicked in the
head and goes to the hospital that
that's that's a high liability case for
you so what are you selling I never
looked at it that way that's very thank
you well what's your company what are
you going to sell I am a licensed
aesthetician so I have clients that
follow me and I wanted to go to their
homes and I do facials and peels and all
kinds of things which of course does
affect their appearance I have been fine
and consent but I wanted to start a spa
business so you know I don't know how
often spawns get sued it's something
that that is worth looking up you're
probably kind of in the middle right
it's not karate getting kicked in the
face but it's not selling books online
you know if you if you use the wrong
chemical or they say you did and it
burns their face you know there's issues
there so that's the advantage to go into
a corporation basically what happens is
in a corporation if you get sued they
can only touch the money that's in the
corporation so if you get sued and you
lose then they can only take that money
if if you get sued and you lose and it's
a it's a it's a sole proprietorship then
they can come after your personal house
your car or whatever assets that you
have that's the biggest difference now
so that's definitely that's a good part
of going corporation the the downside of
that is it costs more money so there's a
setup costs and then every year you have
to get your books put together and have
a an accountant help you so it could
cost you a couple thousand dollars a
year maybe it may depend on your account
maybe a thousand fifteen hundred if
you're just starting up but those are
every year you have to pay those costs
to to do your books and your filings so
there's a lot more paperwork involved
with the corporation
but if you get sued then the most you're
going to lose is what's in the business
right so it sounds to me since I am in
the medical field and although you know
it could be the greatest aesthetician
walking this earth and I'm not saying
that I am but there's always the chance
of someone having an issue even though
they sign a consent still possibly going
after one of the girls that work for me
so I don't I think probably I'm leaning
towards corporation after speaking to
you yeah especially if you're thinking
about bringing people on under you as
well you know and they make a mistake
that's that's that's definitely worth
the you know 1,500 bucks a might cost
you a year as it get insurance policy
right obviously you want to train them
and do a good job and you don't want to
get sued that's the worst nightmare for
a lot of companies but it'll save you so
much you know potential money if you do
get sued and you lose I mean nobody
likes to think about that and often the
legals are the last thing entrepreneurs
want to focus on right we want to think
about the marketing and the product and
the customer is not the illegals and the
contracts and the setup and all that but
it's definitely an important thing to do
when you're getting started absolutely
and oh thank you so much I wasn't even
thinking the liability and the suing and
all that I was just thinking of all I
want to make these people feel better
and I've been doing it for some time and
everybody has had wonderful results and
I get to see the results immediately so
they're feeling good but I didn't want
to take on a couple of girls that were
in school with me and let's face it if
I'm not there all the time then it's my
name and my like you said my livelihood
this at risk yeah absolutely and if your
eventual goals are to have your own
space like if you want to have your own
retail shop you're not going to people's
homes you know if they come to your shop
and they they slip on the floor and they
you know break their arm they could
potentially sue you right they have to
win of course but but that's a risk
right so
and any you know you wouldn't you
wouldn't even be able to get a retail
space without being a corporation with
insurance so oh okay thank you that was
great thank you so much for your advice
it's buried no problem Maria good luck
and good luck with the new business well
thank you so much and thank you for
helping all of us all right take care
have a great day thank you bye-bye and
that's the main difference for all of
you guys listening in the liability and
you know if you're just getting started
part time in this low risk you can do a
sole proprietorship that's okay you
figure I'm not going to get sued so I
don't need to spend that extra time and
hassle but if you're serious about your
business and there's any change if
you're getting sued then you definitely
want to get incorporated and you know
that's just a part of the cost of doing
business and protecting your nest egg
your family your home your car
everything that you've built up so far
for yourself today we're talking about
how to have success with your social
media campaigns I already gave my first
two tips number one is listen to the
networks to twitter facebook youtube
google+ linkedin and see people are
talking about your industry your
business number to create accounts even
if you're never going to use them just
create the accounts and nobody else can
squat on your business name okay number
three we're starting easy we're start
with baby steps and moving up because I
don't want you to this is what a lot of
people do they go hardcore and social
right they'll spend two months go crazy
on social get no results then say oh
that didn't work for me this is stupid
and going back to my other ways and they
don't give it a chance they had the
wrong strategy so I want you to start
small make sure it's working for you
before you expand so number three is
monitor and respond so social media
doesn't have to be scary you don't have
to dive in deep all I want you to do is
monitor your name monitor your company
name monitor your Twitter handle monitor
your your YouTube handle right you'll
get alerts if somebody tags you right if
somebody comes to Europe so if you go
back to to Kelly who was starting her
retail store selling Mexican products
right she could have a Twitter account
if somebody tweeted her and said hey I
just went to whatever her name was it
was a great experience or it was a
terrible experience she should at least
know
I just monitor that so you can respond
you can support your champion so you can
you can fix any problems because if
somebody comes on it starts ranting
against you on social you want to be on
top of that and try to solve that
problem as quickly as possible so step 3
you're just monitoring it's super
lightweight okay you're not doing a lot
of activity you're not going to be
posting very often maybe once two three
four or five times a week it's not
overwhelming at all but if somebody's
talking about you it's going to give you
the opportunity to connect with them
this is again how I started right I
started by people were mentioning my
name and I just wanted to be a part of
the conversation because I wasn't
relying on me having an audience they
had an audience and I'm just saying
thank you and giving them props and and
giving them more encouragement because
then they're going to go and do it again
right the more you encourage these
people who have an audience more likely
they're going to keep going out again so
that's three monitor and respond the
next one is just thinking about posting
lightly okay we're posting lightly
you're thinking about the message that
you want to put out there you think
about the good you're trying to create
in the world and you're not going crazy
if you're doing one post a week just to
start one tweet a week one Facebook post
a week just something valuable something
that means something to you don't post
something because you think your
customers are gonna like it post
something because you are proud of it
every post you put up on social you want
to be proud of as a yes I believe in
that I stand for that I love that I this
is how the world needs to be if you're
proud of it then your audience will
respond or if you're just trying to do
by the numbers and say well you know
this post XYZ will hopefully get us you
know why number of views and likes and
comments it's not going to work out you
have to post from your heart but lately
right don't go crazy on it and make sure
you're getting results right make sure
people are commenting about you are
talking about your website or are
mentioning you on Twitter and when you
start sharing stuff make sure again that
you're getting results from that make
sure people are interacting with it and
they're liking you have to prove it to
yourself right imagine you have a boss
who saying you ought to show me that the
social media thing works prove it to
yourself that it's were
your time investment on all the social
platforms i'm posting multiple times per
day but i did that after building up the
proof that i know that this works for my
business ok so to recap number one we're
listening to the network see if it's a
fit number two we're creating the
accounts number three were monitoring
and responding and number four we start
to post slightly I'm going to share some
more tips later on but first when i get
to the calls i have Denise on the line
Denise where are you from and how can I
help I'm in lake oswego oregon and you
gave me some spot on advice about a
month ago for my nonprofit the brides of
Eden and I have another question alright
welcome back things I I planned a big
event for our nonprofit and I needed to
sell three tickets or grab a sponsor in
order to pay for it and I took at that
so I was trying to attract the
professionals that are good at it to do
it for me and I was offering them a
percentage of ticket sales or
sponsorships because I had no money to
pay them up front one of them said they
were offended by that that's not
non-profit language isn't it okay to be
entrepreneurial as long as I put money
in the bank and spend it on the missions
for sure okay because I was feeling icky
after they attacked me well that's not
all nonprofits work well I guess I don't
really get how nonprofits work but I'm
just trying to get it done isn't it okay
to do what it takes to get it done hey
this guy doesn't sound entrepreneur at
all did so are you are you registered as
a non profit or not for profit I am a
non-profit program under a 501c3 that's
sponsoring me so yes I have a tax-exempt
status right okay perfect so you can
perfect yeah with with every yeah it's
funny because nonprofits there's so many
who have such a great cause and they're
so bad at business that they struggle
and then they struggle on donations
what's wrong with selling something and
actually making money to fund the
programs that you're trying to get out
there right I don't think there's
anything wrong with it as long as I make
money and spend it on what i said i was
going to spin
it on who cares how I get there as long
as it's not illegal yeah and and
obviously is a non-profit year you're
held to you know you're gonna you might
have your books on it and people make
sure that you're spending X you're
spending the money how you said you're
going to spend the money but it's a
great idea at so many nonprofits rely
just on donations and and often it's not
enough if you had a product that you can
get out there and seller or events that
you trying to sell tickets to if you can
make extra money as a non-profit and
pour that into more programs why not
yeah I mean I have to I have to have
money to do the next thing and I have to
pay professionals to help me get there
so the only way i can pay them right now
is to motivate them by giving them a
percentage of what they bring in I
didn't see anything dirty or
unprofessional about it so I just wanted
to check with an expert ya know I it's
just you're dealing with the wrong
person for sure absolutely well thank
you for confirming that cuz I'm hurt
them on the right path but I'm making it
up as I go along as I have all along is
an entrepreneur but I just have a
different tax status that's all yeah and
this will be an important part as you
grow your business as people listening
grow their businesses to the people you
bring on your team have to be aligned
with with what you are all about not
just like here's what we're trying to
accomplish but from from a personality
point of view from a from a you know
here's my values here's what I believe
in they have to be on board and it's not
just the skills right because you can
look at somebody who can sell and say oh
I'm really need that person to come on
board you know they have the right
skills they really complement me because
I know I'm week at those things which is
a great understanding for you but they
have to have the right values to write
somebody who sees this as I don't know
what he said was unethical or dirty or
not right what did he say yeah I mean
it'sit's that's never going to be a pit
for you right it's never going to be a
fifth you'll never work with that kind
of person and and you don't want to
waste your time trying to convince them
that you're right in there
because it's not going to work it's
better for you to move on to find
someone else who who hear it and say
yeah that's finally a non-profit whose
entrepreneurial that's amazing I want on
board well I keep remembering what you
told me last time which was such
precious advice that I don't need to
apologize for making money as a
non-profit it's a new era it's a it
really is because most nonprofits don't
think that way yeah the more money than
we can spend and find a way to spend it
all yeah launched new programs impact
more people that's what we're trying to
do right yeah thank you so much I'm
still living off the advice you gave me
last time and I feel much better having
talk to you again so I really appreciate
this down all right Denise no problem
what's do you have a website for your
your nonprofit yes it's bride to
video.com brides of Eden calm all right
give a give a quick promo shout out
there for you thank you all right thanks
Denise and hey if you have any more
questions problems concerns i'm always
here call back in and be happy to help
you I will do it thank you and for
everybody listening in two important
points here really one you know just
because your nonprofit it doesn't mean
you can't be entrepreneurial doesn't
mean you can't find new ways to generate
money besides asking for donations and
two you really need to pay attention to
your team and and Denise did such a
great job of listening to her heart and
trust in her gut that you know this
person coming in just even though they
had all the skills you're going to get
faced with this often somebody has all
the skills that you need and you
desperately needed to work right you're
really trying to get this program going
you need it to work I need this person
on my team i can't do it myself and you
really want that person to work out but
if they're not on the same page with you
if they don't have the same values if
they are not bleeding and oozing what
your your organization is all about then
it's never going to be a fit and you can
invest all the time you wanted to try to
improve them and train them and make
them better but you can't change values
you can give them skills but you can't
change values and what they believe in
so congrats on using these keep up the
great work
today we're talking about having a
social media strategy that works for
your business that generates leads for
you and I've been sharing my formula
okay there's six six steps here so we've
gone through a few of the number one
listen see people are talking about you
and your industry number to create
accounts just to hold them just in case
you want to use them at some point
nobody steals them number three monitor
your name monitor your website that
people are talking about you at least
you want to be able to respond number
four is posed lightly so now you're
sharing some thought leadership pieces
you're sharing some things that you
believe in but lightly once a week show
that those results see that you're
getting traction before you expand okay
this is where a lot of people fall down
because they dive right into step 5 in
step 5 is you create a Content schedule
sep five is where you are posting
regularly maybe you're posting once a
day maybe you're posting multiple times
a day you know on youtube i post twice a
day on twitter i might post with
responses to people 20 times a day or
more you know facebook from posting five
six seven eight times a day just
depending on the day and the schedule so
you know you want to make sure that
you're getting value from those
interactions before you rent up it's
critical okay so if you shouldn't you
have some results you're getting some
traction people are sharing that people
are engaged by you have people saying I
really love what you posted you're
getting traction you have some kind of
call to action to sign you up for your
newsletter or visit your website then
you start creating the content schedule
and again with every post that you make
you want to make sure that it's adding
value to people's lives that it means
something to you that you're proud of it
every post has to pass that I'm proud of
this post test so here's here's
something you can post so here's a
sample schedule because it may be
thinking well I don't know what I would
post once today how do I get enough
content to post once a day here's
something you can do so monday you could
share an industry article that you enjoy
so you're doing research your
understanding your industry you're
you're reading articles share one that
you really like don't just don't just
put up something that you haven't really
ratting you like the title and it's from
a magazine that you know is typically
good make sure you actually have read
the article and then add your two cents
don't just share the article but tell me
why it's important to you what did you
take out of that article right you could
do that every Monday and all you need is
one article that comes from what you're
normally reading every day anyway number
two on Tuesday you post a quote that you
found inspiring all right son quote that
you've read online in a book in a video
something that just lifted your spirits
that got you motivated you know as
entrepreneurs it can be hard to say
motivated every day in our business and
whatever inspires you if it's a quote
that you've read or even an interaction
with a customer post that up because
it'll help keep you motivated but will
also it'll also help motivate and
inspire the other people in your in your
audience people who are watching the
people who want to be a part of what
you're doing so so post up that's every
Tuesday and you can find one a week to
put up number three Wednesday you can
ask a frequently asked question that
your customers ask so what are what are
some of the questions that come in from
your customers on a day to day basis you
know if I'm thinking about you know
company I invested in here called
Toronto day and salsa have salsa classes
people might ask well what kind of shoes
do I need where can i buy them do you
have a DVD you know all the typical
questions do I need a partner was a
great beginner song that I can dance to
right you're going to have a lot of the
same questions that come up over and
over and over and over again but to be a
lot of people who have those same
questions who never actually even ask so
put it up on social one question per
week and answer it for them provide that
value because the people who might be
too afraid to ask we'd be sitting on the
fence now they're getting valuable help
to go to to learn more about whatever
industry that you're in potentially buy
your product Thursday share an
interesting fact about your business
tell a personal story right like let me
connect to your company and and you as a
person more than just whatever product
or service you're selling right the more
you can make it a brand that means
something to me the more likely i'm
going to want to to buy from you and be
loyal and tell my friends about you and
care and not just compete on price right
not just say oh well you know your
competitor drop their price by five
cents so i'm gonna go there so share
something interesting share an
interesting fact tell me why you started
tell me you know how many customers you
have tell me you know who your
first employee was tell me what your
first media gig was tell me what other
three business ideas you were thinking
about when you first started tell me
your biggest fear when you're getting
going tell me the first thing your
customer said to you tell me your
biggest fear you know when that first
custom walked in the door whatever tell
me something right find one interesting
fact I just listed off you know ten
there that sets you up for for a fifth
of the year answer those and then keep
coming up with more right so you can
post one of those once a week on your
channels on Friday post a picture post a
picture of you post a picture of your
team post a picture of your customers
again we're making it personal right
post something that when I look at I can
get some kind of feeling towards who you
are what you're all about something that
shares the values that you're trying to
send out there going back to our one of
our callers Kelly who had the the
Mexican goods you know she could take
pictures of her product she could take
pictures of her trips she could take
pictures of the artisans and the
villages that that she's buying these
things from so I feel like if I'm buying
this I'm supporting that little tiny
community in Mexico right that kind of
personal connection means so much more
i'm willing to pay more for that then if
I'm just buying jewelry why should i buy
your is over another people persons
jewelry another company's Julia right so
having those pictures really help and
even if you're just showing pictures of
your of you and your team working you
know showcase one of your team members
show kiss one of your contractors make
that stand out so that I feel a personal
connection to your business on Saturday
you can ask people a question awesome a
fun question you can ask them something
totally unrelated to your business like
what's their favorite food or TV show or
what are they doing this weekend or ask
them something related to their business
you know I asked them about what what
next product they want is to see come
out and ask them about how they're using
your product or service in an innovative
way ask them ask them you know what new
innovation I'd like to see you to launch
right ask them a different question
every week it bonds into your company
more and it also gives you information
about who they are what they're
interested in and how you
potentially sell more to them and then
on Sunday you can do something more
promotional Sunday you're you're sharing
one of your blog posts you're sharing
the press release if you have a coupon
you can put it on your sharing your
newsletter you're sharing a new product
that launched something more promotional
it's okay to have some sales related
stuff in there but just don't make it
constant so that's a that's a quick
overview and you don't have to do that
every day of the week and you don't have
to do all of those pick and choose
sample but make sure you're posting
content and you're getting results from
it and step number six is your test you
measure you test you rinse repeat you
find out what works find out what feels
right find out what you're getting
engagement from your customers on
because social is so important
especially 2015 it can be one of the
leading drivers for your business I hope
you take the opportunity to invest in it
and and start driving your business
forward this year thank you guys for
another amazing show it's been awesome
Christy Josh you guys are amazing I'm
hopping on a Twitter chat right now if
you guys want to follow me on Twitter
we're talking social results I will see
you in two weeks thank you guys so much
take care hi I'm tour epsilon from time
management chef calm Adam comidas
NewsCenter ethnic subscribe
you